comment s'appelle-t-elle grosse Amy tu
t'appelles grosse Amy oui une brindille [ __ ] comme
tu le sais et fais-le derrière mon dos j'espère
que tu ajouteras ton propre cardio non je
ne me mets pas pour le cardio tout le
temps de laisser tomber un smash ce que je  je vais juste
pomper et vider oh désolé mes seins sont tous
fous je sautais juste des déchets pour bébés j'ai le
sentiment que nous devrions nous embrasser
j'ai parfois le sentiment que je ne pouvais pas faire de
la méthamphétamine en cristaux mais alors je pense mmm mieux
pas oui des crocodiles luttés  et les dingos
simultanément vous allez recevoir des
gifles si dures que vos seins d'homme
vont concaves bienvenue en Espagne Bella
donc c'est la première base allons-nous
aller à la deuxième base avec vous les gars
c'est un non de ma part
c'est beaucoup trop de courrier
oh  merde
es-tu prêt tu dois auditionner pour
les Bellas je ne peux pas me concentrer sur
ce que tu dis as-tu couvert
ton travail tu sais que cela fait reculer les femmes
comme 30 ans c'est du travail
je serais ravi de commencer je suis désolé je
ne  Je ne dis pas content, je ne dis pas des trucs comme
ça, c'est moi  faire des choix je suis plutôt cool
tu vas m'aimer
beurk je voulais juste te voir
avant les mondes on va te botter le
cul
juste parce que tu me rend très
confus sexuellement ça ne veut pas dire que tu
es intimidant qui es-tu  personne
littéralement personne qui était mauvais pour Reggie
est-ce Reggie
Rebecca cela arrive souvent même si vous
seriez surpris que cet air mort entre nous soit
un bon signe de
retour j'ai les mêmes chiennes Oh
que voulez-vous regarder en premier nous faisons
quelque chose d'autre que nous pourrions revivre le
divorce de mes parents visiter un gynécologue
réalisons cette affaire ici
tout le temps je suis juste petit je pense que nous
devrions le changer en souris fougueuse Chris
Rock tout le monde vous êtes vraiment ivre en ce
moment je ne pense pas que vous  Je vais me souvenir de
tout ce qui n'est pas choqué du tout, utilise Larry Je
peux voir ton toner à travers ce jean
c'est ma [ __ ] Je t'aime super nerds
Becca qu'est-ce que tu fais ne fais pas
si tu pleures un peu pleure ne fais pas cette
tête je suis  ne le fais pas ne fais pas
cette tête  c'est mon visage habituel